for my ultimate special occasion lunch
I've got some stunning
I mean stunning lobsters and I'll be
cooking them very simply with cheese and
garlic butter serving them with Bloody
Mary linguini I'm gonna start with a
pasta sauce
I love the indulgence in this dish if I
was doing this for the kids I'll scrap a
vodka and just do like a Virgin Mary but
a bit of a grown-up's dish now pan nice
and hot
special olive oil onions in season such
as salt pepper garlic be nice and
generous with the garlic it's not just
your average tomato sauce it's a royal
stunning smother sauce and you're in for
a big treat season the onions and garlic
for you Tabasco
that'll give that really nice lift
little pinch of celery salt spice that
up with Worcester sauce and instantly
colors its martyrs goes brilliantly well
with a celery salt Tabasco and that nice
careless garlic and it will light
sprinkling of sugar all the Worcester
sauce has reduced down we've got this
nice sweet spicy sticky garlicky onion
base glazed with a couple of spoons of
vodka in
Oh chop tomatoes in will touch the water
look at the color on that sauce
seasoning
that's delicious bring down to the ball
and cook it out six to eight minutes
reduce you down slowly turn down the gas
and then that simmer with my sauce
simmering I can move on to a delicious
bread crumb topping to dress my linguine
now file my bread crumbs get them nice
and crispy I don't put too much oil in
there otherwise the bread will just
absorb it they become greasy beautifully
seasoned them and they go really nice
and golden-brown 30-second before they
come out that leaf parsley roll that
through your bread crumbs that is gonna
finish the linguini and top in here a
crisp Avira before I cook the linguine
I'm gonna make the chili butter that
will flavor my lobster get your chili
you can slice it I want to take
advantage of all those seeds julienne
touch of salt a nice close of garlic
yessum parsley
[Music]
start breaking that down I'm looking for
a lovely garlic chili paste exactly I've
ass now don't overdo with the butter her
butters are a great way to flavor fish
and meat they can be used as a stuffing
in dishes like chicken Kiev or Adi
towards the end of a dish as a delicious
glaze lobsters they're already cooked so
firmly place the lobster flat on your
board there's a little crisscross here
lying there and a line going across put
the point of the knife in and just push
through the head turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster snap the legs
off snap the claws off just get the back
of your knife crack them spread that
beautiful butter on go into the heads as
well and then the claws take off bits of
the shell and get it all bits of butter
in there this can be done way in advance
for me the longer that chili butter sits
on top of that lobster the better the
flavor especially when they hit the
grill
while my lobster firms up in the fridge
I can finish cooking my linguine water
brought up to the boil seasoned nicely
and a little touch of olive oil now
linguini him first that's gonna take the
longest 8 to 10 minutes in and as a
linguini stars softly at the bottom just
gently turn that around always wait and
linger when he's nice and soft that way
you don't break those nice strands give
it a good mix do you lid back on bring
that to the ball rapidly after 8 to 10
minutes my linguine should be perfect
you want it al dente slightly firm mmm
I'll teach you it absolutely spot-on
train that into a colander and shake a
little bit water from the pasta into my
sauce and sugars start twisting the
linguine around on that Bloody Mary
spicing up the linguine always hold up
the center of the pan first and place it
onto the plate let go of that nice big
lemon by doing this you'll get a
mountainous pile of spaghetti with more
body then generously cover that will
crispy bread crumbs absolutely beautiful
last but not least I need to cook my
chilled her buttered lobsters on a
smokin hot griddle that butt has gotten
really nice and firm so the idea is
snapping that down and grilling the some
of that chili and garlic butter is
extraordinary because the lobsters
cooked all you're doing is grilling that
delicious spicy chili butter you just
want that mark of the char quickly on
the lobster turn that over smell is
incredible
get that on
[Music]
you understand why it is proper
special-occasion food because that is
mind blowing
[Music]
griddled lobster with chilli and garlic
butter serves with a boozy Bloody Mary
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch and turn nice and gently nice
going with the grain it's almost like
slicing through butter